French president Emmanuel macron will
speak to Congress this morning after
finishing a two-day visit with President
Trump their relationship was put on full
display yesterday the leaders held
private talks on the Iran nuclear deal
North Korea and Syria followed by a
public show of friendship at a White
House state dinner but they still have
important differences on how to tackle
big international issues major Garrett
is at the White House with mcrawlins
effort to influence president Trump
major good morning good morning as
expected the two leaders clashed in
private over the Iran nuclear deal that
very frank discussion those are the
French president's words appears to have
yield at a different reality president
Trump still likes that Obama era Iran
nuclear deal but sounded more open than
ever to other options in fact by the end
of the day it was hard to keep track of
all the possibilities to that underlying
deal floated by mr. Trump tonight we
celebrate nearly two and a half
centuries of friendship between the
United States and France the state
dinner honoring the president and first
lady of France was the culmination of a
two-day public display of affection
thank you I like him a lot there was
hand-holding kissing and even an
intimate cleaning off of president
McCrone collar we do have a very special
relationship
in fact I'll get that little piece of
dandruff we have to make them perfect he
is perfect but that sunny disposition
has its cracks most notably on the Iran
nuclear deal it's a bad deal it's a bad
structure after an intense round of
talks the president warned Iran not to
follow through on a promise to resume
nuclear activity if the u.s. quits the
multilateral deal if Iran threatens us
in any way they will pay a price like
few countries have ever paid okay the
French leader came to Washington to
persuade the president to stay with the
deal and build upon it McCrone spoke of
a quote new deal that would limit Iran's
ballistic missile development and help
blunt terrorism in the Middle East his
pitch appears to have made some headway
with the president but we'll see also if
I do what some people expect whether or
not
it will be possible to do a new deal
with solid foundations on North Korea
mr. Trump said summit discussions are
progressing he used strikingly positive
language to describe dictator kim
jeong-hoon a sharp turn from that
critical nickname little rocket man he
really has been very open and I think
very honorable from everything we're
seeing the future of US forces in Syria
was also a big topic and there also
appears there to have been a macron
effect with the president acknowledging
the French leaders underlying point that
pulling US forces out too early could
create an opening for Iran the end of
the day the president said world leaders
must demonstrate flexibility in John at
least while the French president has
been in town
president Trump has shown just that
major
that's fascinating thank you